hey guys it's justine happy iphone week
this is the week that a lot of us have
been waiting for and
you better believe i basically have been
waiting for this week since
last year of this week i've been posting
a bunch of fun iphone videos you haven't
seen it already i did an unboxing video
a camera test and there was a recap from
the event so what you guys are here for
is the what's on my iphone so i'm going
to be kind of going back and forth
between phones
this is not only a what's on my iphone
but it's what did i forget to install on
my new iphone video before we get
started a huge thank you to lastpass for
sponsoring this video i've been such a
huge fan of theirs for a really long
time and one of the things that i think
is most important about this
is if you are one of those people out
there that use the same password for
everything this is a message for you
please do not do that and think about
your digital security because it is such
an important part of life now
lastpass allows you to store all of your
usernames and passwords in one place in
ios 12 and android devices it'll
automatically fill in your passwords for
you so you don't have to worry about
remembering them
my favorite feature is that it will auto
generate some passwords for you because
trying to come up with different
passwords for every single website and
everything that you sign up for is
extremely difficult you can generate
different passwords for every single
account because one of the most insecure
things that you can do is have the same
password for every single login that you
have on the internet so if you are one
of those
people i just i'm pointing this finger
at you
so if you want to check out lastpass
i'll put a link in the description and a
huge thank you again you guys are
amazing so now moving on to
what's on my iphone i'm already stressed
out because i'm seeing apps that i
forgot to download but so far i've been
absolutely just loving this phone so of
course we got lastpass which we talked
about we've got the clock
maps notes app store phone okay so far
so good
the apple music app settings instagram
instagram tv i just
just want to ask a question do you use
instagram tv
what do you think about it how do you
feel about vertical video i would love
to hear what you think leave those in
the comments below twitter facebook
amazon prime now i'm not sure if you
guys have prime now but prime now is
incredible because it can basically
deliver things within an hour depending
upon where you live we got the youtube
the youtube studio app the activity app
so that connects to your apple watch and
that tracks your activity
snapchat starbucks very very important
so anything from that first page that i
probably should have
over here this is kind of my catch-all
folder got the wallet
books tv stocks news itunes store
photos reminders weather basically
everything that comes pre-installed on
the phone facetime
home health compass the measure app oh
boy let's get measuring
okay okay well i guess i'll just measure
it to there
okay that's cool let me measure my old
iphone
five and a half man how fun
i'm into the measure app okay keynote
calculator itunes u
pages numbers files the apple watch find
friends podcasts find my iphone contacts
voice memos
and that's all that's in that folder
i've also got the clips app i'm excited
about the new clips app update i believe
they said in the
keynote that they will hopefully have a
vertical video update
because i feel like there's not a good
vertical video editor
not sure if it's i don't think it's
implemented yet but that is going to be
something that i'm very excited about
imovie dji co pilot boss this is pretty
neat so
there's a hard drive that you can
connect to your phone but it also has an
sd card reader so you put the sd card
into the hard drive
plug it into your phone and you're able
to transfer the files to the drive also
to your phone
test flight this is an app that
developers can send you application
requests for you to demo their software
ronin that's for the ronin that's what
it is
the ronin is a steadicam if you don't
know what that is the apple store on
demand this is an on-demand yoga app
it's a part of core power yoga which is
right below it
they have studios all over the place so
i'm not sure if they have them where you
are
if they do let me know play memories app
this connects to my sony cameras i'm
able to
transfer photos and videos over to my
phone wow we
we need to turn notifications off
because i'm going to
gonna go crazy trying to film this video
all trails this
is a hiking app so it's kind of cool
because it is also user generated so if
you ever go on a hike somewhere cool you
can add that trail to the database you
can leave comments and all kinds of
things
okay well i'm not logged in on this
phone yet you can download the maps you
can record your trail you can check in
you can leave comments about it
and it's pretty cool because you're
getting real feedback from people that
have done the hike earthmate this is an
app that connects to my garmin
satellite phone so it connects to the
phone so i can send messages if i'm out
in the wilderness and don't have
reception
um netflix i think you guys know what
that is pulse mates basically the only
way that i can survive and feed myself
so there's also siri shortcuts so this
is kind of cool because you can create
different shortcuts for things so if you
say
hey siri um whatever oh gosh
create shortcuts for anything so if you
have siri set your alarm for the morning
you can also be connected to the
internet
that's another phone that's over there
talking to me
the next app on here you guys are
probably wondering why does that say
naked
there's a mirror called the naked mirror
and it is a 3d mirror that you
stand on the scale and it rotates your
body and with that you're able to get
body mass you're able to get a lot of
different dimensions from your yourself
other than just weight
it's been very interesting using this to
track my fitness progress because
you see it real time you see everything
i'll probably do a follow-up video soon
but if you want to see the original
unboxing video that i did i'll also put
a link in the description and an
annotation
kayak for booking airlines and hotels
airtable is something that i use
to kind of keep my video ideas all
in one place frame io is cool i use that
if i'm uploading a video and someone
needs to give me feedback on it
fortnite i think you guys know what
fortnite is rezzy that's for
uh restaurant reservations brook burke
body i
am a huge brook burke fan and i've been
doing some of her workouts recently
especially when i'm traveling it's easy
because i
basically have brooke on my phone
telling me what to do hq trivia you
can use my code ijustine i don't really
play as much as i used to but man
what a fun concept for just a game show
cube that's a period app caffeine it's a
live streaming platform i'm sure many of
you guys have seen that before dji go i
use that to
control my drone hue lights for my
lights
in my house element oh my gosh i keep
saying it wrong elemento
tie it too memorize i talked about that
as well in the unboxing video it's
a language learning app so it will tell
you how to say things in other languages
so let's explore it thinks it's a camera
but i mean i guess that's close enough
but like it's a lens
so sometimes it's not entirely accurate
night sky i also talked about that in
the video dropbox where you can store
photos videos content uh facetune oh my
goodness
me and jenna we did a facetune challenge
where we facetuned each other
honestly i think i'm done uh-uh i think
i'm done
oh my gosh i can have glitter there's
rainbows coming in shut up
oh this looks very so far that's all i
have in my app i
have the bottom here stored with my
texts
my email safari and the camera is there
anything else that i forgot
on here that i might need i don't think
so
well thank you guys for watching i hope
you enjoyed this video let me know what
your favorite apps are and if there's
any apps that i'm missing that you think
i definitely need on my phone
let me know in the comments below but
for now i'm going to enjoy
this very minimalistic app page
and you're probably also wondering why
because now i'm just noticing it that
i don't like to have anything on this
bottom row because i like to have
my finger be able to float freely and
not touch any apps
it's silly but now i have more screen
real estate on this phone so
that allows me to leave that extra space
so that's it
fun story i'll see you guys in the next
video bye